coming back with his second start since
coming off the il list he lost that last
ball game but he pitched very well he
never gave up a run to the fifth inning
ball to strike sound colton wong and he
hits this one hard
right field all the way back and gone
for colton wong and how about that for a
follow-up to the no-hitter the brewers
are up one to nothing and colton wong
with his eighth career leadoff home run
his sixth this year
and a good two-strike pitch slowed down
that curveball and yellow right over the
top eric lauer on the hill for his 17th
start he's been pretty good since the
beginning of july
and a strikeout to open up for
eric lauer a good start to the game for
him
2-2 to ramirez and he can't check his
swing and he is run up for strike three
so one two three inning for
lauer
two for seven in the series pitch is a
swing and a line drive towards the left
side it's gloved by rosario throw wide
and it's into foul territory in right
field peterson's going to try and score
here comes the throw it's going to go to
third sliding in there is urias brewers
are going to get another run
on a really bad throw by a med rosario
it'll be a base hit for luis urias as it
stayed on the infield ahmed rosario his
only play was going to be at second base
but just a really bad throw and nobody
backing the play up of course mercado
the right fielder not assuming that
rosario was going to be making that
particular throw here's manny pina drew
a walk in his first game back on friday
from the injured list had some oblique
tightness
and then the drama sets in pina to right
that's going to be a base hit that'll
play the run for milwaukee azarez comes
in and vogelback just beats the throw to
second base
good for manny chiming in offensively
coming off the injured list he came in
as a pinch hitter you know back in the
game on friday he drew a walk escobar
two for 10 in the series here's the 3-2
and this one hammered into ryder clutch
two-out base hit for escobar as
vogelback scores
and the play at third pina gets back in
time and the brewers now lead at four to
nothing boy escobar really starting to
heat up
and a close play at first and it looks
like they got him the car on the field
is out dan iasoni the first base umpire
looks like he rings him up that's a heck
of a move right there i mean and a good
snap tag i mean not even close out by
lead
plenty
the brewers and the first pitch brought
home and garcia rips one high and deep
down the left field line and it is gone
avi garcia with number 26 on the season
and that ball was blasted out of here
down the left field line from garcia
411 feet for avi garcia and now here's
manny pina rbi single back in the second
inning for manny
and this one hammered to left field
watch this one fly
a home run for manny pina his 10th on
the season another two out base knock
for milwaukee and they extend that lead
now to seven to nothing manny pina
coming off the injured list swinging it
didn't he
first offering and this one's hit hard
out to center field jackie racing back
at the wall johnson makes the catch
jackie bradley jr getting some steps in
in center field to start up this inning
he put one foot up against the wall
leaped in the air and caught that ball
and saved extra bases
off the bat of levarnway here's the
pitch from perez
swung on and that's blasted high in the
air deep left back on it is ramirez
leaps at the wall and makes the catch
right up against the 19-foot high wall
ramirez made the grab bounced off the
wall and fell over but hung on that's a
nice play by harold ramirez one pitch
one out here in the fifth
there's a swing and a miss
and fran reyes is down on strikes
0-2 pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out
back-to-back strikeouts for eric lauer
give him seven payoff pitch to chang
swing in the miss he struck him out
lauer strikes out the side in a perfect
fifth inning
this one to third nice play by ramirez
but a high throw
wipes it out and pina will score the
brewers now lead it eight to nothing and
they don't record it out i think a
little bobble over there by ramirez not
sure why it took him so long to get rid
of the baseball
kind of hesitated a little bit lauer's
ready the left-hander with a one-two
swing and a liner up the middle base hit
center field the no hitter
ends with one down in the sixth there's
ryan lavarnway with the line shot to
center
and the indians have their first hit
since friday night in the ninth inning
up the middle again three straight picks
right up the middle
levarnway waved around and the indians
are on the board
all three hits just going the same
direction right back through the box
stay on the baseball is right cole wong
is coming up he's two for four homer to
open up the game pitch from shaw
swinging a high fly how about right now
way back for wong a new career high for
colton wong his 13th home run of the
season his second of the game 9-1
brewers
that one got out in the blink of an eye
and for colton wong another multi-homer
game for him this year second time he's
done that this season
oh my goodness look at this one go
halfway up in the stands and left second
home run for garcia
and the brewers are blowing out
cleveland right now it's 11-1 i'm
telling you abby garcia has hit two of
the hardest home runs we've seen this
year
erin ashby back out on the hill for the
third consecutive inning of work rock
and a chance to pick up a save and a
10-run lead ashby picks up another
strikeout
nice pickup by
eduardo escobar for two down
[Applause]
and reyes can't check his swing
and it is over five strikeouts for ashby
and his first major league save
and a brewers sweep
of the cleveland indians 11-1.